whether or not you're a sports fan you
may have noticed a recent poll
suggesting one in eight men believes
they can win a point of the world class
tennis player Serena Williams now Serena
Williams has won 23 Grand Slam titles
she's one of the longest ranking world
number one female tennis players of all
time so what makes 12 percent of men
look at all that and think yeah I could
take a point of her part of it is
overconfidence something that shows up
across other professions to the stats
suggest many women will only apply for a
job if they are 100% qualified whereas
men who meet 60 percent of a job spec
will apply but there's something else
going on here too
every woman has come across the man who
just thinks he is better regardless of
actual expertise experience or
qualification this person is exhausting
to reckon with demoralizing and
undermining and judging by the social
media response to this story
it seems I'm not the only one to think
it's time he got well and truly served
oh the nation roars with laughter as I
start this conversation but what what
are you looking for you want legislation
that stops this you want a quantum shift
in how men view themselves you want
society to better police itself because
I mean it is ridicu bloke thinks they
can take a point of serum there must be
bloody nuts
netball I probably could have done well
against the so what what is it you're
actually looking you know you do have an
uncanny knack for asking all the wrong
questions about what I'm looking for my
marriage is yes there's an observation
here about how this dynamic plays out
not just in world-class sport where we
see women at the top of their game
literally get treated very differently
their confidence is interpreted
differently their celebration of their
talent
is viewed differently but this also
plays out as I've said in other
professions as well mainly the
interesting thing about this is you know
this this stuff that I this stuff that I
was showing you about the 60 people this
men who are 60% qualified apply when you
drill down into that actually it's not
just confidence that stopping women from
applying its playing by the rules in a
way that men don't think not mentioning
a recent the recently appointed prime
minister in order to rise in their in
their careers in their profession I want
more money for the Navy care wants more
money for dementia what do you want in
this era money Nick gender point thank
you but across the piece women are
basically put in a up their box often by
men if there seemed to be getting out of
their Lane as we saw a bit when the u.s.
women's soccer team triumphed so I think
there is a bit of that but I'd like to
say something
counter to it which is that we don't
want it to go so much the other way that
only girls are being encouraged to be
confident and to apply things that I'm
the mother of two sons in their 20s and
I think that we have to also acknowledge
that you know it's not a piece of cake
for men to you know find themselves and
self actualize and be the best at the
moment and it's not just girls we should
be worrying about admittedly though
let's just quickly hear from a former
cabinet minister penny mordant who at
one point was women in equalities
minister women work harder but they earn
less and they save less if you don't
want women to end up at the end of their
life with not enough pension with not
having saved with having felt that
they've not had the choices in life to
really develop their own talents we've
got to actually look at why that is what
I felt when I Teresa Mays last p.m. cues
which I don't know if you will watch she
was asked by Joe Swenson a female party
leader what her legacy was and chateaux
Theresa May said she wanted her leg back
there so II didn't know when I think of
girls growing up in Eastern
Martin sure it is inspiring for them to
see women in positions of power whether
that's as First Minister of Scotland or
as Prime Minister of our United Kingdom
can I ask the Prime Minister what advice
she has for women across the country on
how to deal with those men who think
they could do a better job but are not
prepared to do the actual work I think
my my advice to all women is actually be
true to yourself persevere keep going
and be true to the vision that you are
working for I mean I basically agree
with you I think there is from my
expensive in organisations in the rest
of it women are less likely to push
themselves forward are less likely to
apply for jobs that I think men are
called sometimes because they've worked
out and I think quite cleverly they've
worked out actually the job they've got
is better than that one you know
so where's men semen ever willing to
push themselves into middle man
determine which other most boring jobs
in the world it I suspect it's not just
about women there's a class structure in
this as well I mean there's a certain
sort of my rule comes from a certain
sort of background who went to a certain
sort of school who seemed terribly
confident about what they're gonna do in
life
now I do think there are other factors
that play ethnicity diversity you know
class diversity all these things show up
in different ways but I do think what
it's interesting what you're saying
about management because quite often I
think that women potentially don't go
for managerial positions because they
know that management requires a certain
way of behaving that is not received
well when it's come from women I you've
seen as bossy rather than leadership I
think to the point of these delusional
blokes who think they can take a point
off Serena Williams you know she could
be blindfolded sitting down having a
glass of wine and she could still beat
them all 65 silver could take a point of
her own home service at a hundred miles
an hour it's a joke but a but I think
it's what we're talking about yeah I
wish I had the confidence of a mediocre
man please God give me a confidence of a
mediocre man
because you're right and I remember
years ago going no I'd only see your
listen I have a very good friend who's a
psychologist and she she says I have
something called impostor syndrome
because I truly believe and and don't
all agree at once that I'm not very good
at anything and I and I just feel sorry
for psychologists just called the human
condition Carol we all feel we all do
men don't have I know so many men who go
home from work on a Friday and think
thank God they didn't find me in years
ago I went for a paper I was working for
I went I've never asked for pay rises I
can't do it and it's exactly about that
I don't think I'm with it so I went to
see this guy who was in charge as
managing editor and he said you're the
first woman to come and see me and ask
for a pay rise in ten years yeah you
said women really don't do it and I and
Anna and I thought then did you get it
yes I did get it he gave me he gave it
to me he said you're the first one who's
never done it this is something that the
former u.s. first lady Michelle Obama
has spoken about she said she said in
December 2018 I still have a little bit
of impostor syndrome it never goes away
that feeling that you shouldn't take me
that seriously what do I know I share
that with you because we all have doubts
in our abilities about our power and
what that power is so this is someone at
that level that has that sense that
you're describing Carol but in my
lifetime I've got no bloke in my
lifetime it has there has been a change
without any doubt and what will be
interesting to do is to measure that
change and it says they're still
continuing wait how long will it take
before in part I think mayor what men
have impostor syndrome just like women
but probably not as much yeah okay now
there's going to be no shortage of
material from our new prime minister
Boris with Wathan Johnson he's barely
taken a step inside number 10 and we
already know Bojo will give us golden
moments to rival the time he was left
dangling 20 feet in the air after
getting stuck on the London 2012 Olympic
zip wire and I'm excited to say the do
to our fan
after connections naming no names the
pledge have managed to get an exclusive
insight from the man behind the blonde
bravado he is talking to skies Sara
Jamie on Sunrise earlier this week he's
an larger-than-life and very physical
isn't he he is he's also got a way of
looking sort of slightly puzzled and
bewildered with everything and this
allows this spontaneity to come through
and I think we did see that at the
speech yesterday that ah yes this is
where we'll have to see the more formal
pooris outside number 10 with the
lectern in that very official way the
job beginning right here is it just me
or is there something slightly off about
our new prime minister well I think most
of us could agree that imitation is the
greatest form of flattery
isn't that right Jon Culshaw for that 10
out of number 10 impression of the most
powerful man of the country Jon you are
our dead ringer of the week how good was
that good or not social they were and
the like you know the world remembers
mr. the arrival of bosses is a godsend
any other places you've just had you've
just had to reason might you couldn't do
and now they'll have great fun in there
look good - good - well it could be it
will be a good few weeks Oh a good few
years we don't know okay that's it for
this week but if you want to join in the
debate just search for the pledge on
Facebook or Twitter and you can now
listen to the program or the girl with
Apple podcasts thanks for watching we'll
see you next time
[Music]